hey guys Pete here this will be my recap
breakdown for Watchmen Episode five the
episode was titled little fear of
lightning which is an excerpt from a
line from 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
by Jules Verne the full quote being if
there were no thunder men would have
little fear of lightning
although the danger is in the lightning
not in the thunder the episode was
written by Damon Lindelof and Carly Rae
and directed by Steph Greene we take a
look into who Looking Glass is and this
was the first Watchmen episode that
really recreated the magic of how the
leftovers used character based episodes
to tell the story we get a ton of
answers about what's going on but it's
all wrapped up inside Wade Tillman's
story that is compelling enough to stand
on its own Watchmen episode 5 takes us
back to 1985 where a young Wade has
traveled with a group of Jehovah's
Witnesses from Tulsa to Hoboken New
Jersey because the Doomsday Clock has
been set to 1 minute before midnight
tick tock Wade as he navigates the
carnival as viewers were treated to a
buffet of Easter eggs
veidt's method on the back of a magazine
there's a show poster for pale horse
who's playing at Madison Square Garden
and we also meet a group of not tops we
learn about these guys in the original
story in fact a group of them actually
killed the original knight al who was
Hollis Mason so when he approaches them
it's not surprising that they give him
some [ __ ] it is a little surprising when
the one girl who's with them though
actually rescues him and pulls him into
the funhouse to hear more about the end
of the world in that conversation LG
says he isn't afraid of anything when
she presses him and it's all due to his
faith but that faith is immediately
tested the girl takes his clothes
leaving him naked and humiliated and
before he can even really process all of
that the squid attack happens we see the
mirrors fall down around him and it
brings the terror of how this attack
would play into focus I can't speak for
someone who has this background but
presumably he isn't afraid of the end of
the world because his faith tells him
that something better is coming as a
result as he walks out and screams what
happened as he sees all the dead bodies
we get a glimpse into
but a post 11 - world has to deal with
adrian veidt's plan was to avert the
impending nuclear war by giving both
sides of the conflict a bigger problem
to worry about that part worked but his
plan never really included a remedy for
all the fear that was left behind with
the survivors of this attack fear of
nuclear annihilation played a huge role
in watchman fear of what happened on 11
- plays a huge role in looking-glasses
life and he wouldn't be the only one we
find out there support groups that
Steven Spielberg made a movie called
Pale Horse about the attack in this
universe rather than Schindler's List
and there's at least one company that
profits off selling equipment designed
to protect from extra-dimensional
attacks to transition back to 2019 we
get this great long shot it's sort of
like a flyover where we leave him at the
carnival and travel to Ground Zero to
see the aftermath as the squid sits in
the middle of the city it's an absurd
idea and a gruesome image they really
pulled this off and it Wade's cover job
as a focus group consultant we see that
even 30 years later they're still trying
to get people to come back to New York
for tourism this is a way depa sewed and
we follow him to the police station
where we see that he takes his job
seriously we see him visit his ex-wife
who is a geneticist where we get some
insight into how their relationship fell
apart and watching horror as she
incinerates a cloned puppy that is
slightly smaller than the original we
watched him butt heads with Laurie who
takes every chance to rib him about
wearing masks and bugs the cactus on his
desk because she's FBI and they bug [ __ ]
and we see him prepping doing anything
he can to regain control and protect
himself from the next extra-dimensional
event it consumes him and we see that we
learned that he's a big time customer of
extra-dimensional security products
which include his early warning system
and reflect a teen which is a substance
that's supposed to protect his gray
matter against psychic blast like the
one from the squid in New York reflect
the teen was a real kicker we found out
that his mask is made of it and that's
why he wears it even inside his own home
Laurie nails it when she throws out the
idea that he became a cop after the
white night because that gave him an
excuse to wrap his whole head and
to teen most of the time rather than
just hiding it under his baseball hats
he wears tinfoil hats like for real all
the time sitting in the support meeting
wait spells out to the group how he
deals with his PTSD the idea that the
squid saved humanity which would have
been destroyed by nuclear war if the
event had it happen this may be helpful
to them but we know it's BS and so does
Renee who we later learn is a member of
the 7th Calvary sent to infiltrate the
group and lead LG to Senator Kean they
have a drink talk about their trauma and
why isn't everyone terrified they kiss
and then well lettuce at the 7 K secret
hideout Wade learns that the church from
the video was actually a set built in an
abandoned department store so Lori's
planned to find it probably won't turn
anything up he sees that they are
experimenting with teleportation devices
that were supposed to be involved with
the squid attack on 11:2 and learns that
Senator Kean is the leader of the
cavalry from what Keene says he's doing
this for the right reasons and so was
chief Crawford who also got involved
with the group after the white night to
help keep things under control
this means that angela is a real problem
for Keene because she threatens to
disrupt things by digging into
Crawford's backstory the senator offers
LGS quid pro quo help him get Angela off
the board for a couple of days so that
they can continue with their plan and
he'll show LG the truth so that he'll
never be afraid of extra-dimensional
attacks again that gives us a scene with
Wade Tillman watching the Wallace greens
just like the star of the video
Ozymandias aka Adrian Veidt did at the
end of the comic book the video itself
is a little strange it doesn't really
present anything new to people who read
the comics bytes plan that he lays out
here is the plot of that book but this
is a huge revelation for Wade and that's
what's important for this watchman story
Tim Blake Nelson masterfully shows us
how this affects his character without
saying any words there's relief
understanding and there's a sense of
contentment and bliss that could be just
under the surface waiting to come out if
only for a moment his mind can
rather than preparing for that next
attack and this is some great television
in my book think about the horror on the
young Wade's face as the camera pulls
away from him screaming at the carnival
on 11 - then think about this scene and
the 34 years that have passed in a life
in-between think of him wearing his
tinfoil hats as an attempt to control
that feeling that it could all happen
again at any time then think about the
hole that's gonna be left behind in him
when that fear is removed and we can see
the tragedy that is this character Wade
Tillman on top of it all mr. glass is
put in a no-win situation Keane
explicitly promised to set the cavalry
to the task of killing Angela and her
family if Wade wouldn't help him get her
off the board back at the station he
follows through and gets sister Knight
to reveal what she's been up to in
relation to Crawford's murder she tells
him that she found her grandfather will
at the crime scene and covered that up
which he knows Laurie's gonna hear
because of the bug cactus it's enough to
take Angela into custody but not before
she downs the bottle of her granddad's
nostalgia pills which sets up the next
episode things aren't over in
looking-glasses story though he returns
home and struggles with the hole that's
left inside him where his fear used to
live he decides not to put on the
tinfoil hat and promptly throws his new
extra-dimensional security system in the
trash before turning around and grabbing
it again before entering the house after
that some well-armed 7k guys show up in
his driveway and they look like they're
on a mission we don't find out what
happens because the episode ends but it
doesn't feel like Keane is keeping up
his end of the squid pro quo for what
it's worth I don't think they're gonna
kill Wade there's a chance mainly
because I don't think they're gonna open
the next episode and we're gonna find
out that he died I think it would have
worked better if they were gonna kill
him to kill him at the end of this
episode it's just my opinion but we'll
see how it plays out in outer space we
catch up with Adrian Veidt who actually
launches himself outside of the barrier
of his prison wearing his improved suit
he manages the touchdown on the surface
outside where all the phillipses and
Crookshanks clones have landed damon
lindelof confirmed to Collider that he's
on Jupiter's moon Europa
and we watch as he uses the corpses to
spell out save me D that's all we can
read anyways in a way that the satellite
that's looking on and we'll see them as
he celebrates just like he did at the
end of the comic he's yanked back into
the prison by the game warden who
definitely looks like a Phillips with a
mustache and a mask on under closer
inspection Oz he yells at everyone in
frustration saying your gods abandon you
which invokes dr. Manhattan clearly and
weirdly the game warden agrees that it's
likely their God won't return that
doesn't stop him from doing his job
though and he arrests Veidt promising to
show him no mercy for the fifth week in
a row we get some answers to what's
going on with Ozymandias but we still
really don't know what to make of what's
going on here
like I said that clearly invokes dr.
Manhattan with the talk of a god the
fact that they're on Europa who else
could get there how would they do that
but we still can't say for sure what's
going on here and it won't stop us from
trying to figure it out that's what
we're supposed to do and that's where
things are left as this episode comes to
a close in the PTP do we learned more
about the Nostalgia pills that have been
the source of many theories over the
last couple of weeks since they were
introduced by will this was a marketed
pharmaceutical product it was supposed
to help with anxiety and depression what
they do is they take some of your good
memories they encode it in these pills
and you experience that feeling when you
take it just like any real-world
pharmaceutical there's a lot of warnings
on the packaging and we got the news
from Wade's ex that they were taken off
the market because they cause psychosis
we end watchmen episode 5 with sister
night taking a whole bottle of nostalgia
not her own but her grandfather's which
is a big no-no according to the
packaging don't take anybody else's
nostalgia and there's also the idea that
you know truths using this may be for
other purposes maybe she's advanced the
technology we don't know what's gonna
happen to Angela for sure but we can
guess that it's gonna make for a really
interesting episode 6 some of the other
things that popped up in the episode the
friends and Nemo thing was kind of funny
Nemo is the captain of the submarine in
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea which we
mentioned at the beginning
think the way that they moved on from
the squid into this story is really good
I think this is probably one of the best
episodes maybe if not the best episode
of the season so far all the
world-building they did in the first
couple episodes is really starting to
pay off these little details of how the
world is and how things function feel
right at this point as much in the tape
of Ozymandias is a little bit weird a
lot of people are bringing up the idea
why would he even make this he made it
in the past
apparently the show Robert Redford after
he gets elected and it's a smoking gun
which isn't really even necessary if you
wanted the exposition of what happened
in the original story you could just
look it up on the internet like they
didn't necessarily have to tell us in
this way and it doesn't feel very
Adrienne bite for him to lay out all of
his crimes in a format where they could
come back and haunt him I don't really
know what to say about it I guess if you
hadn't read the comic and you couldn't
take the time to figure out what the
original story was about that this might
be useful but I think it might be a
little bit suspect I'm not jumping on
any conspiracy bandwagon here but the
ideas in the back of my mind
speaking of theories and bandwagons I
really loved how Panda was convinced
that could a justice was dr. Manhattan
he's watched all the episodes that was
really funny to see them talking about
that at work him with Red Scare
discussing the theories about the show
kind of referenced all of us and what
we're doing right now the hooded justice
and captain metropolis sex scene may
have been a little bit out of place if
you didn't know the backstory of those
two characters they were rumored to have
a relationship and the show references
this again in the PD PD afoul this week
as well of course
Agent P doesn't like the series he sort
of takes the role of an angry gatekeeper
about how they approach making this
stuff into a TV show and we'll have to
see how they handled the reveal of
hooded justice the TV show seems to be
on a path to explain something about him
theories are certainly pointing to it
being will the truth may not be
completely clear at the end but either
way we're gonna learn something
important about that in the next episode
I'm sure Keane's plot is interesting I
haven't seen a lot of conversation about
this but he does have something play
and it is going to happen soon it
involves that teleportation technology
that we saw them messing around with and
I for one I'm really curious to see how
that will play out and I'm looking
forward to getting more will and trying
to figure out what lady throughs doing
in relation to that in the next episode
so I will end it here make sure you let
me know in the comments what you think
was this your favorite episode what did
you think about looking-glasses origin
story how they tied in the original
story to the one more watching now what
do you hope to see in the future my next
watchman video will be the trailer
breakdown for episode 6 that will come
out in a couple of days so make sure
you're subscribed to my channel if
you're not already please like this
video if you enjoyed it you can follow
me on Twitter and Instagram for regular
updates during the week thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon